this is buddha and this is pesht
together it makes budapest
this is the river danube this is some
paprika this is a huge parliament
building and this is some paprika they
have a delicious selection of fruits and
oh my god there's paprika paprika
paprika i mean it's everywhere
this has to be a thing
[Music]
this is a paprika pepper once it's cut
dried and grinded down it makes this
paprika powder and here in hungary it's
a big deal known to locals as the red
gold this spicy ingredient is in pretty
much everything hungarian goulash
chicken paprika stuffed cabbage i mean
in some places it's even next to the
salt
here at the great market of budapest
well you guessed it we have a huge range
of paprika from all over the country we
use it for almost every hungarian food
and it's very delicious we even have a
museum and a festival dedicated to
paprika really yes
welcome to paprika monarch museum
my name is anita molnar and i am the
paprika historian paprika is a very
common hungarian spice that was created
about 200 years ago in this region in
sagat
it is a spice it colors your food red
and we hungarians tend to maybe overuse
it but we love it
originally it was brought over to europe
by columbus therefore the mother plant
was definitely some kind of a chili
people who were trying it they figured
it was a lot like black pepper for
people who couldn't afford to buy a very
expensive black pepper they started to
use the fruit of this plant as a pepper
substitute
[Music]
but nowadays it's not just used to food
isn't that right peter
yes definitely we have some paprika soap
you know the soup has some paprika
aromas it doesn't hurt when when you
wash your yourself but that's not all
they've got paprika flavoured honey
paprika flavoured polinka paprika
flavoured chocolate
everything paprika okay back to the
kitchen this stuff may be ancient based
on some of the city's most modern menus
[Music]
let's try this
oh my god
so good
[Music]
you